I Can Only Imagine
what it must look like to have all of
that egg on her face Joy Reed after her
her debate with Chris Ruffo where she
gets everything wrong and she says that
schools aren't teaching critical race
Theory because uh well now we have
actually the largest teachers union
backing approving a plan to teach
critical race Theory which is rooted in
Marxism and to provide resources to push
back on anti-critical Race Theory
rhetoric and uh sit right in front of me
there are a bunch of books from schools
including one workbook for school these
are for kids right yep how to be an
anti-racist by Abram X candy now I do
think we're we're gonna have a long and
important conversation about what's
actually going on in these schools what
critical race Theory means and why it's
it's more than this and I think critical
race Theory isn't doesn't go far enough
in explaining what's really happening
because something else is happening
a creepy authoritarian cult is
indoctrinating your children that's
what's happening and there are those
that believe in Merit and there are
those that believe in
I don't know I guess communism you could
you could that's what you could call it
it's not capitalism it's like we March
around saying like we're all capitalists
but we do believe that if you work hard
you can succeed these people don't
believe that they believe you're either
oppressed or an oppressor and nothing
will ever change that so go to them for
political answers I guess it's
authoritarianism and it's creepy because
what they're doing right now is very
similar to what happened and I'm gonna
go there we're gonna go cliche World War
II Nazi Germany yeah it's what the Nazis
sought to do take the children away
because you may sit here saying you
don't like any of this stuff and we're
gonna win but they're going for your
kids this is why it struck a nerve it's
why the backlash has been so massive
it's why they are struggling to push
back and why they're now openly
accepting and Publishing that they are
going to be teaching your kids Marxist
theory essentially critical race Theory
an offshoot of this in a variety of ways
so we'll talk about this and we'll talk
about the the ramifications of this cult
ideology how about this for example
what was her name Gwen Berry was that
Olympic Athlete a few years ago she's
standing holding an American flag with a
smile on her face now she's on the
podium angry covering her head angry at
the at the national anthem what happened
to make this bright and cheery
individual waving the American flag so
disdainful and and hateful of her own
country it is this cult and it is a
world of pessimism and darkness so we'll
talk about this joining us to talk about
the latest news and what's happening in
these schools is vice president for
parents defending education azer nomani
thank you so much for having me here is
there anything else you wanted to add to
uh introduce yourself well I'm a mom I
am a survivor I
just saw my son graduate from high
school and we have survived this assault
on children and I'm here because
I believe everybody in America needs to
wake up everybody needs to know that we
have a real threat I'm motivated by a
love of this country love of children
and hope for the future I do not want
toxic ideologies sucked into any child's
brain to basically turn them into angry
disaffected human beings on this earth
like our job is to make sure that
everybody kind of has this path to a
positive life and we have to stand in
the way so I'm part of this movement of
Mama bears and pop bears that are
basically standing in front of school
boards and refusing us and and this is
so important because this could be the
straw that breaks the camel's back it
could be the crack and the dam that you
know ruptures it completely Steve Bannon
said that come August 15th when these
parents see what their kids are learning
you're going to see some so you're going
to see something that he thinks we're
going to win yeah we it exploded it
exploded last year my wake up was in
June 2020 when I found out that the
principal at my son's High School across
the border here in Fairfax County
Virginia Thomas Jefferson High School
for Science and Technology decided that
we the Asian parents had privilege and
we needed to check our privilege and why
by the way while we were at it we needed
to get rid of the colonial mascot
because what a representation that was
of racism and oh while we were at it we
needed to fix the admissions process so
that we our demographics at the school
could match the demographics of the
county which meant a purge of Asians and
that just happened two weeks ago we'll
get into that we have an article that
you wrote we'll talk about that yep we
got to Yin Chillin yeah I mean these
osri brought I don't know how many 15
books at least that I'm looking at this
is just it's so jarring to see it face
to face because I hear about it but to
think that these books are now are being
in this embedded in the school system
man it's starting to freak me this this
book is creepy dude the color is like
it's blue and the red there's just like
for little kid candy for kids that
matter notebook they ask you to fill out
like these are workbooks for children
yeah
I mean you you give this to a a grade
schooler yeah I would have
done so well on it and memorized it and
written it to heart if I was told to do
it right I mean you would have been just
filled in like this is fill in the
blanks right like we we gotta quickly do
that we got to show some of these
questions so we'll get into all this
because wow wow we also got Lydia I'm in
the corner and I'm really excited for
this conversation because people
constantly are asking us what can I do
to make a difference well here's a
lovely lady who started uh down the path
to make a difference so I'm excited I'm
feeling good about the future before we
get started head over to timcast.com
become a member and you'll get access to
exclusive segments from the timcast IRL
podcast we had Dr Chris Martinson on
last week and I can't even show you the
title of that podcast because YouTube
would banish if I did no joke not even
kidding just the title of it if I scroll
down on our own website that's why we
set it up that it's a tough question
what do you do I mean look you've got
some pretty evil people trying to
manipulate children that's there's
seemingly No Limits to the depravity
you've got the the Democrats coming out
saying we always wanted to provide
funding for the police it's the
Republicans who don't
we got a story now we're going to go
over where there's a democrat in San
Francisco talking about how almost half
of San Francisco wants to leave due to
the crime and the lower quality of life
it's hard to have these conversations
when YouTube censors you so that's why
we set up timcast.com so the good news
is we're really close to launching the
Paranormal unexplained podcast and that
means if you're a member you'll get all
of that content as well we're going to
keep just adding more and more to the
culture building plus we have more free
content coming we have journalists who
are already writing articles the new
website should be launching in the next
week or so we've already gone over the
alpha it looks fantastic we should be
moving into Beta And I think the beta
will be public and then we'll go through
the bugs but become a member at
timcast.com help us stand up for good
ideas and uh with your support we're
gonna keep making awesome content but
don't forget
to like this video subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friend
if your friends if you're listening on
any podcast give us five stars give us a
good review let's take a look at this
first story which basically contradicts
everything the activists have said
uh up until I guess this point
from The Daily Mail America's largest
teachers union backs teaching critical
race Theory to Children says it will
fight those who oppose the move and
calls for October rally to commemorate
George Floyd's birthday so this is it
we've heard over and over again that no
one's teaching critical race theory in
schools it was a semantic game what
they're actually doing was they were
they call it Praxis theory and practice
so they weren't teaching you the
writings of say Kimberly Crenshaw they
were applying the ideology that she had
written about into the teachings of
these schools and they're using
derivative writings or ideologies like
anti-racism and critical white studies
to indoctrinate your children
now the cat's out of the bag the
national Educators Association announced
it is backing the teaching of critical
race theory in schools the country's
largest teachers union approved a
resolution to promote critical race
Theory and assemble a team to teach it
to union members it also wants to
assemble a staff take on those who
challenge its plans to promote CRT in
addition to its plans the Nea will
launch a national day of action on
October 14th George Floyd's birthday to
have a dialogue on systemic racism
as of June 29th 26 states have
introduced bills or taken steps to
restrict teaching critical race Theory
it is unclear how the nea's plan to
teach CRT will be implemented in such
States
I I gotta say
I read some history
I am not optimistic we're we are we are
we are repeating uh humans are repeating
themselves in this regard if you look
back to the 1920s and what was going on
in Germany I know it's extremely cliche
to invoke Godwin's law and say oh
they're just like the Nazis they're not
in the sense that they believe the same
things although actually they kind of do
racial identarianism but you take a look
at what happened in the 20s what
happened with uh you know Hitler being
this this uh what do they call them uh
the leader of the reactionary extremists
and then eventually he won over the
country and the reason he did it and his
own words is that he indoctrinated
children right so that's what we're
saying so here's here's where there's
some optimism though
Steve Bannon said on this show what was
it a week a week or so ago that we are
going to win we're going to defeat this
this Marxist ideology the critical race
theorists and the establishment just
take a look at what's happening in
Loudoun County with these parents who
are fighting back against critical race
Theory when these moms start seeing
what's being taught to their children
right they're going to wake up and then
he liken it to the French Revolution
yeah he said once the women the wives
came out that was it right that it was
over they marched down to the Palace
they took you know the king the queen or
whatever yeah so maybe what we're seeing
now with the work you're doing Israel
and and all these books you have to show
us is it's it's cause for Hope yeah I
mean it is cause for Hope because
we got fed up we got fed up we just
decided okay we've got our you know
carpool that we got to do we got to make
dinner we gotta make a living but we're
not gonna let garbage go into our kids
minds and so that's what happened in my
life and I know that every parent that I
speak to is equally motivated
there's you know nothing that will stand
between a parent and their child because
love is what connects us and it's
existential this is a being that you
brought into this world you can lose a
lot in this life you can lose a job you
can lose a home but when when your child
is in the threat of being taken from you
in spirit and in mind there's nothing
that's going to stop you we saw this
viral story last year where when I
started doing Zoom courses like the kids
were now doing remote teaching the there
was a there was a leaked video
apparently some teacher was like I'm
really worried what's what's going to
happen if the parents find out what
we're teaching their kids right and the
parents found out what was being taught
to their kids yeah we we listen and you
know what happens is we're just shocked
because all of a sudden you have
entrusted the school system with your
kids life and now you see that in fact
your child's future is threatened
because they may end up in this very
regressive mindset and that's troubling
and so from New York City to Beaverton
Oregon you know we've got parents that
are standing up we've got teachers what
we've done at parents defending
education has created a little portal
and in that portal people report to us
their tips and we put their tips we
investigate them I've been a journalist
30 years and I do the reporting and we
all do the reporting we've got Erica in
Rhode Island we've got Marissa here in
Virginia we've got Nikki and Virginia
also and parents all over the country
that are part of our movement and we're
putting them up on the map so that
everybody knows in every school district
what's going on something crazy that's a
uh well well I think people are familiar
with the high profile battles that are
happening the Loudoun County being one
of the the biggest you have these
parents that they're in these videos
they're going viral yeah because
effectively what's happening is
these schools are teaching children that
they either are oppressed or oppressors
right it basically Marxist theory and a
critical theory and they're saying which
is basically the same thing but I
digress they're saying to these kids
like minorities you will never succeed
you can't succeed you're oppressed it'll
never happen yeah and there's no
solution offered up to that ideology you
tell someone you will always fail have a
nice day yeah and so you're creating
that bigotry of low expectations for
minorities and then Asians when we say
actually we like math you know and our
kids are good at math and uh and they go
into the stem schools like my son's
school we're the inconvenient minority
right and then they want to dismiss us
as white adjacent and that's just white
now yeah they don't even bother they say
whiteness is this critical race theory
that it's a property that's that it's a
tangible thing owned by people and that
if you're accepted then basically Asian
people can be white now here's the funny
thing our friend Luke who is Lucas is on
the show very soft and he has blonde
hair and blue eyes he is white but he's
Slavic so according to the Coalition for
communities of color
they say that he's a person of color as
a Slavic individual blonde hair
blue-eyed white guy yeah yeah because
ultimately the identity shouldn't be
defined by these abstract ideas and
speaking of whiteness this is one of
those books that's actually sold and
taught to elementary school kids called
not my idea the most startling page is
this one now this is this is in schools
this is in schools Christopher rufo
tweeted about this yeah this is this is
one of those books it's taught in in
Pennsylvania it's taught in Texas and
what is it let me let me read something
yes whiteness is a bad deal it always
was dude we can see your pointy tail
what does that mean turn go to the next
page it says contract binding you to
whiteness you'll get stolen land stolen
Rich's special favors whiteness gets
quote uh check mark to mess endlessly
with the lives of your friends neighbors
loved ones and all fellow humans of
color for the purpose of profit your
soul sign below land riches and favors
may be revoked at any time for any
reason
and the pointy tail is on a white man is
on the devil yeah the contract with the
devil and that's what whiteness has and
this is going to third graders can you
imagine that a third grader has to
process nine-year-olds yeah basically
this kind of garbage it's really
toxicity that's amazing I mean when I
was a kid we didn't learn is there
complicated Concepts yeah a child yeah
and if you want to talk about
colonization and you want to talk about
you know some of these moments from
history you don't associate it then with
this every white child that exists in
classrooms today it's really well it's
it's funny how
um there's none of it makes sense to be
completely honest I mean they say Asians
are white adjacent then they say agents
are actually white then they say stop
Asian hate right right
they got to do their virtue signaling
right they gotta act like they care but
ultimately they don't care because
they're out to destroy Asians uh pursuit
of Merit Merit exactly yes what is it
about Asia that they get lumped in with
whiteness and perhaps it's the
stereotype of the stern Asian parent
telling their child to work harder are
you a doctor yet you're not why not keep
studying yeah and that's that's the joke
and they don't like the idea that I
suppose that people pass down
studiousness I don't think it's racial
right I think it's cultural yeah and I
think what we're really talking about
right here is they call it cultural
Marxism
but I think it's very communistic in the
sense that they don't want you to
believe you can succeed because then
what happens you're dependent upon the
government you're dependent upon some
extern external structure or system to
provide for you because you're oppressed
you can't do it right in in that book
when they mentioned that contract with
whiteness yeah do they offer up any
positives of how to succeed and how to
overcome being oppressed well you have
to get rid of your whiteness you know
first of all as a human being and then
you have to say that racism is what
brought you down right and you have to
have this acknowledgment of that and
then it's very culty yeah it is very
culty and and this is all the the books
and literature of a cult and that's what
I think is parallel in what you said
about Nazism I mean I've heard you also
talk about how critical race Theory you
know isn't the concept that we should
put out there we should just call it
wokism right well yeah I mean I mean
whether it's true or not like it's an
ism it's an ideology and that's what got
me into this because as a journalist I'm
always looking at ideas and how they're
sold and how they're marketed out in the
world and that's what I then realized is
that there's this multi-million dollar
industry pushing this ideology and into
our schools spineless corporations to
see a quick Buck our book a quick buck
and in a book willing to push it yeah I
say wokeness because critical race
theory is has some specific ideas and
there are derivative ideas that don't
rest inside the writings of critical
race theorists like and and they use
these semantic games to manipulate so
perhaps identitarianism might be a
better way to describe it and the reason
I like segmentitarianism it's it's
effectively the the the etymology is
identity plus you know government form
of government yeah so you have
government on the basis of race right
granted it's very vague considering
everything they're talking about because
it's deeper than just just government or
policy but they're very much so pushing
a way of life and policy based on your
race very much so like the Nazis did and
so if you want to find that that common
factor between the authoritarian groups
do they hold the same economic use no of
course not and it becomes very silly
when people say oh so-and-so is a
fascist it's like the fascists had
specific views on the state and
corporations and the Nazis had very
specific views on on Race
authoritarianism is the better word but
that's really broad the thing that com
that binds these with the similar with
what we've seen in the in the past
hundred years is racial identitarianism
combined with authoritarianism I don't
care what kind of economic system you
have if you're an authoritarian in the
first place and then outside of that
race-based authoritarianism is just a
million times freakier yeah and you know
I've I fit really well in the oppression
Matrix because I'm a Muslim I'm a woman
I am an immigrant I lived in poverty
when my family moved to America grew up
in West Virginia
and so I I could make out pretty well
right in this suffering yes but the
reason why I care is because this ISM
that really
woke me up that was in my life was
islamism which is the political Islam so
as a Muslim I grew up with a very
Progressive interpretation of the faith
I didn't grow up with thinking that I
had to cover my hair I brought as
another show and tell this doll who
looks like a typical Barbie but when she
arrived her name is Fula and she had her
hair covered she was wearing the black
Abaya that women have to wear right in
Saudi Arabia and you'll see that I took
her to vote with me one day I got her
the voting sticker because uh you know
women have been denied the vote in these
islamist countries so there's being a
Muslim and then there's believing in
Islam that is about your identity and
about
um politics it has to be in governance
and so for the last 20 years after 9 11
I've been fighting that extremism and
that's where I really understood this
identity politics
divides people it's dangerous it kills
people and that's why I know that the
battle we're in is so important and
there's an interesting point we made too
with identity politics there's sort of a
positive identity politics and a
negative identity politics and I think
it's hard to know exactly where the
dividing line is certainly we view the
Civil Rights act as a good thing you
can't discriminate on the basis of race
what we don't like is identity politics
where they say you must discriminate on
the basis of race so that's what I'm run
into was with many of these left
personalities they're like aha when you
say Civil Rights Act you're playing
identity politics and I'm like I'm
saying you can't use someone's you know
race to discriminate and then they say
you can but it's really fascinating
though we they then say you can't
discriminate on the basis of sex they
say it's a really confusing thing to be
completely honest but maybe we'll get it
in a second I want to do this first
because what I want to talk about
critical theory and general critical
gender Theory the big battle in Loudoun
County is actually over a transgender
policy bill so it's not just race Theory
but I gotta I got I gotta pull up this
book I was looking at this book we got
this how to be an anti-racist by ibram X
candy ultimate summary lessons goals
checklists and action plans is made
press so what is this what is this
insane book so this is a book that you
use while you read his book that Fairfax
County Virginia for example spent twenty
four thousand dollars buying and
requiring children to read and so then
you get this workbook that accompanies
it and you would have loved it right you
would have just filled in the blank you
would have said oh okay I have to go
this is my next prompt you would have
been a great student going through this
workbook so tell us some of the great
questions that they've got in there well
I want to go to the to the let's go
let's go to the back let's see what we
got
okay
um those are action steps
first I'll just point out they have
these these areas where you can write
lessons number one queer racism a strong
collection of racist policies leading to
inequity among race sexualities that can
be substantiated by racist ideas as
regards race sexualities queer
anti-racism is the phenomenal Gathering
of anti-racist policies leading to
equity amongst race sexualities for
authentication by anti-racist ideas on
Race sexualities every race sexuality is
unique
did that mean anything I feel like I
missed the steps yeah I miss something
sexuality it answered the question yes
yeah it's so intentional word salad
because they want to confuse people and
make them dizzy with their assumptions
they have so many strange assumptions in
every sentence here's one in what ways
can you be a successful gender and queer
anti-racist yeah exactly like what what
yeah and then you just fill the blank in
yeah fill the blank in explain why
everything about race is tied to lay
down policies that predominantly cause
so much harm to other racial groups
explain why everything about race is
tied to lay down policies that
predominantly cause so much harm to
other racial groups what what yeah what
is he say is he saying that his own book
about race
is harming racial groups or is he saying
that they're restricting it cause harms
to racism he needs a copy editor yeah
seriously
his goals in number one and you got to
write you got to fill this in
in what ways has your sexuality been
threatened how did you go about it and
what would you have done differently
what what how old are the kids who get
this these kids will be high schoolers
okay okay I mean still come on oh yeah
for sure it's it's basically you're
getting this Bible for critical race
Theory handed to these kids for a
required reading and then you're getting
his own nonsense repeated back as if
you're supposed to treat it like it's
intelligent prompt it's garbled nonsense
I mean yeah so here's another one and
again you got to fill out the blank map
out the modus operandi you intend to
begin in helping to protect and shield
vulnerable homosexuals and heterosexuals
henceforth wow yeah is that what high
school kids need yes and so what's
what's the hidden agenda there it is to
turn our kids from being students of
knowledge into activists yes I mean
that's the bottom line teachers have
said that I love this I love this
chapter 16 failure it says race is a
social construct not a power construct
what yes
racist racial history
as a singular match of racial progress
and not a combat of anti-racist and
racist progress
did you say racist racial history yes
this is terrible right racism problem
being ingrained in ignorance and hatred
and not powerful selfish interests
it says the racial history of failure is
tied to failed Solutions and policies
the failed Solutions and policies are
due to failed racial principles there
are several wrong Notions of race we
need to debunk before we go further this
is circular it feels like a fever dream
have you guys ever had like strep throat
right right right exactly things don't
make sense but if you can believe it
like so he's become the poster boy for
this right he's being uh twenty thousand
dollars for one hour Zoom call you ready
for this one the school district's pay
this is what they're asking children
they're asking okay maybe teenagers yeah
why do you think the black skin makes
non-black uncomfortable I read that
verbatim by the way the black skin yeah
makes non-black uncomfortable yeah non
this is this is like Robin D'Angelo it
is when she said she wrote what did she
write in her book that she was like she
went to a party with black people and
she felt really uncomfortable around
them I'm like that's you dude you're
racist problem yeah yeah that's not a me
problem and then if you have and then if
you've internalized some messages about
yourself like don't go projecting them
on others and all they do is project
yeah yeah and so there's I well I'm so
happy about is so many of the black
parents that are emerging and saying
this is not what how how we want to
raise our kids like they're in Loudon
they're in Fairfax there's there's a
great movement there are you a
behavioral racist or anti-racist and
what are your attributes based on your
chosen position yeah you're either a
racist or an anti-racist oh so it says
are you a or b and after you select that
yes you are one of the two yeah no but
here's here's the point both racist and
anti-racist believe in discriminating on
the basis of race yeah there's no
anti-racism from even Max handy is we
must it's it's in even Max candy has
called for racial discrimination yes
yeah he has that quote where he said the
only solution to pass discrimination is
present discrimination and future
discrimination I'm paraphrasing right so
to tell kids you're either a racist or
an anti-racist and they have to pick one
he they're basically creating this false
choice where it's like well so which one
do you want to be do you want to be the
person discriminates in the base of race
or do you want to be the person to
discriminates on the basis of race sure
yeah a mom was just telling me that this
is just like the Salem Witch Trials you
know as I was driving here are you a
witch oh then we have to burn you at the
stake oh you're not a witch then that
means you're denying being a witch and
then we have to burn you no then we have
to drop you in the in the water and see
if you float right yeah right exactly so
either way you died yeah either way and
that's what they're going after they are
trying to destroy people this is a
lovely notebook that you can Inspire BLM
notebook is this just like for writing
in yes just for your your personal
Reflections yeah so this right here this
fist is called the red salute right yeah
and it's been appropriated they call it
the black Power Fist and that's like
saying it's not the Nazi salute it's the
white power salute it's like I don't
care what you call it dude it represents
authoritarian identitarianism I'm not
interested and then this is now this
this fist is now becoming the stuff of
PowerPoint slides in classrooms it's the
stuff of posters in teachers rooms it's
it just goes it and that's what
fascinates me propaganda again because
this becomes cool for the kids yeah it's
not good somebody on Twitter pointed out
to me that the feminist symbol is
exactly the same fist but with you know
the sign for the feminine and I'm like
how long has this been going on right
how did we not notice right so there's a
bunch of other books what's this call me
Max book you have oh yeah so this goes
into the transgender issue so this was a
book that was read to kids right in
Austin Texas in the school district
there called eans and lovely pages about
a well I don't know I mean do you call a
girl who a boy born a girl who is wants
to be called Max and he takes I mean Max
is actually
um could go androgynous yeah so Maxine
yeah he declares that his parents had
decided at Birth that he was a girl but
he decided no I am not
the grown-ups made a mistake and so
lovely Max is able to find little kids
that he can speak to about it and then
fortunately for him he finds a friend
who is also in the same situation and
has decided that he's a girl and a
support group at school
and there they get to talk about their
identity issues away from the parents
who are wrong yes who were wrong and
made a mistake that's what and so a
really critical part of these teachings
including this one I am Jazz another
famous one right is that the parents
made a mistake so this is again another
Marxist ideal this is from the cultural
revolution right dividing the parents
from the children yes creating
intergenerational Warfare and ultimately
the state knows better than the parent
on how to raise the child do you
remember when the teachers were melting
down over the idea that parents could
now listen to their classes with zoom oh
yeah I know this is why and yeah because
ultimately that in this a whole dynamic
is the idea that the kids have secrets
also that they need to keep from the
parents so you know this is another
issue where school districts are
debating whether or not a child comes to
them and they say they want to be called
by a different pronoun do they tell the
parents and then they have a form on
whether or not they tell the parents or
not because they can keep it a secret
from their parents wow
yeah I have some questions about uh
books like this I was just looking
through the book and in it the the child
eventually you know talking to the kids
at school goes to the parents the
parents have a conversation then the kid
goes to a support group what about uh
children who are previousent what what
about them is not boy or girl right so
they say that uh gender is a social
construct
so is the issue that Max which could be
a male or female name uh Max wants to
wear blue jeans and not a skirt well
that's not anything to do with
biological sex I agree whether or not
someone wears a skirt as a social
construct in Scotland they wear kilts
very similar in some respects yeah
Middle East yeah Middle East they wear
uh what would you call them the gowns
basically gowns yeah men wearing guys
right yeah uh a toga burning man I wore
a dress
it's normal no so so while they say that
gender social construct the way we dress
is social construct a child who has no
concept of sexuality would go through a
biological treatment when what they're
really saying is I want to wear
different clothing
yeah so there's a lot of questions
around that yeah and then what's
happening is our medical system is now
creating firewalls between parents and
children when the kid turns 13 so that
they can have private conversations with
their health care provider away from the
parent I've Evergreen one of these
School these Health Care Systems in
Seattle has just announced that 13 year
olds get their own email address to talk
to their health care provider so that
they can have these private
conversations so you're saying so the
schools and the medical providers are
are encouraging kids to talk about
gender issues they're having changing
their gender and not tell the parents
yeah specifically they don't tell the
parents yeah because what the narrative
is is that the parents are evil that
they bully that they are not
understanding and that they create then
transphobia right so they use all of
their words then against the parents to
create all of these systems that
separate children from their parents
is this um did you said they're just
trying to get this passed in the school
system where where it's happening it's
happening I just read Virginia's new
policies you know they've gotten rid of
the uh father daughter dance
because that's not okay anymore so I
just want to I'll stress this point one
more time before we jump to this this
next relevant story is if someone a
child who has not gone through puberty
has no experience of sexuality
how would that child understand if they
want to undergo a biological process
to to be or not be it's it's
I don't know I I guess the argument it's
a similar argument the left uses one of
the arguments we've seen from many uh of
the uh pro-trans activists is that
if a child doesn't is going to go
through say male puberty
they don't know what it's like to go
through male puberty maybe they wouldn't
like it therefore they've actually
argued that all children should be put
on hormone blockers until they can
choose right right right and what what
they what they fail to understand is
that there's actually uh you know
prenatal testosterone plays a huge role
as well and a child looking at dolls and
action figures and dresses and blue
jeans those are not that there's nothing
to do with your biological sex yeah but
they want kids to undergo a physical
biological treatment for
a clothing or cultural issue yeah and
what's so disturbing to me is that you
know growing up in India and then
visiting there there's always been a
difficult relationship with folks who
are transgender and I always had great
empathy and all and still do to this day
of course I think most people do with
anybody who is you know in this world
like You Want To Live and Let Live the
problem here is that this is an
intrusion now right into the lives of
children into the lives of families of
the decisions of families because I want
everybody to be able to live peacefully
and without harm right we all do we
don't want any kind of harassment
discrimination bullying but this is a
new propaganda that is making it cool
and making it getting ideas in kids
heads that they otherwise wouldn't have
because maybe they just want to wear
blue jeans now let's uh uh let's get
let's go to this this story that's
happened over the weekend I think this
story may be this next story about the
um the Wii Spa have you have you heard
oh yeah I mean look if if these left
leftists really want to go here and I
think they have no choice this could be
um disgustingly a bit of optimism for
people who oppose this this cultural
Marxism and critical race Theory and
critical gender Theory so we had this
Spa in Los Angeles I don't know if you
saw the video Ian no I haven't there's a
woman complaining to the desk that a a
an individual with male genitalia was
walking around in the spa
in front of little girls in front of
women this woman filming was complaining
saying why are you allowing a man to
walk around naked in the women's locker
room and the clerk says we cannot
discriminate on the basis of gender
identity
some guy walks up to the camera and it's
like it's a trans woman it's fine and
the lady is like that's no woman you
know the lady's saying that's you know
intelligence male junk like sorry I
don't care that's not transgender
so people actually are on the left
defending the law that allows biological
males to go into the women's side and
get naked and there's a lot of really
interesting arguments about this but I I
believe this this could be
a very serious problem for these
leftists so antifa shows up so this is a
story from the hill protesters clash in
La over transgender when disrobing and
Spa now I'll say this we don't even know
if the individual is transgender the
default assumption is if a biological
male goes to the women's locker room and
disrobes in front of children it must be
a trans person that's in my opinion
horribly insulting to a trans person
Perhaps Perhaps it is true because the
clerk said we can't discriminate in the
base of identity but did anyone actually
investigate because what if it was just
some guy walking in and exposing him if
there were testicles it has nothing to
do with gender identity yeah it does
that's balls it doesn't matter it's not
gender yes that's sex organs that's not
gender it doesn't matter the law is the
law but that they're allowed to use the
women you're not discriminating on on
gender identity at that point you're
just discriminating on that there were
testicles swinging the law says you
can't discriminate on the basis of sex
oh sex now that's the difference that's
the loss gender identity is different
than sex it doesn't both so this is
where things get really interesting
terms of this argument
so antifa shows up and actually attacked
people who are saying harass the woman
harassed right right yeah there was
another woman who came out and said at
the same Spa a year earlier a a man with
a beard and male privates got in the hot
tub with her daughter
now is that person transgender I'm not
going to make the Assumption they are or
aren't because I don't want to just in I
think it's insulting to trans people to
imply that bearded dudes expose
themselves to Children must be trans
that's insane to me no I there are trans
people who are fantastic people and why
would you immediately assume that
someone doing this in front of children
is just part of that Community right
we've seen individuals who have seen I'm
not going to name this person but I
think everybody knows this individual is
going in the bathroom taking pictures
yes posting you know leaked messages
really disgusting disgusting abusive
things so
now here's what here's what gets
interesting
the law says uh or I should say a
certain
um
bits of Precedence from the courts
they say that you are allowed to
discriminate on the basis of sex so long
as the same amenity is provided to all
to both sexes so in the instance of
California there are individuals who
sued over the women's only programs like
women learn to code and the court said
so long as the school offers up a men's
program or a program that men can access
it's not discriminatory to have women's
only programs that same logic applies to
bathrooms it is not discriminating the
basis of sex if there's a men's room and
a women's room
the interesting thing is the Court's
basically saying
everyone is equal they get equal access
but they're separate and I see the
problem with that argument
that's what we saw back in in racial
segregation they said it's not
discrimination because everyone gets a
bathroom there's a there's a black
bathroom and a white bathroom they're
equal but separate now what's
interesting is now what's happening is
they're letting folks cross over well
now under that same premise they're
saying biological males regardless
should be allowed to go into women's
locker rooms and kids locker rooms I
mean this is becoming the parent issue
then you know where
moms don't really feel comfortable with
this on an elementary school level and
that's where they push it too far and
instead of hearing people out and trying
to understand why folks aren't
comfortable
they call you transphobe or they call
you you know racist if the person
happens to be of a you know person of
color and trans because this is what
even Kennedy's taught them that there's
all these layers of intersectionalism
that you can now call people with when
you smear them during Occupy Wall Street
there was a really interesting conflict
because somebody at Occupy Wall Street
was raping a bunch of women yeah and
they didn't want the police to come in
because it could disrupt Occupy Wall
Street so they put a poster saying avoid
this man avoid this man you know wanted
for these things they said if you see
him throw them out but don't call the
police
so after a few of these crimes in fact
one of the individuals who was raped was
a trans man and I believe the other was
just a a just a woman
they set up a safe space for women
they were like we're setting up a tent
only women to keep them safe where they
can go to be away this created a huge
conflict because all of a sudden you had
people saying first you have people
saying it's discriminatory to say only
women are allowed to be in the safe
space what if I want to be in the safe
space right they're like well too bad
for you then women uh uh uh feminists
like the modern uh version
said well trans women should still be
allowed even though they're biologically
male then the feminists the the gender
critical feminists said you can't allow
biological males to a safe space for
women who have been victimized
especially if they've been you know
raped by a man and the whole thing was
just chaos they ended up with like in
one instance they had different working
groups one was the women's working group
and one was the women's working group
but one didn't allow trans women because
gender critical feminists were fighting
with right Tran Pro trans feminists and
the whole thing just became rather
chaotic and what's important what were
the years again that that was 2011. yeah
and so just think that that was the the
battle and that was 10 years ago that
was all of this in in the left community
and then you move fast forward to 2017
and remember the women's March they
wouldn't allow the Zionist feminists to
come in right so this is this has been
this this has been the direction and now
we're in the schools so like there you
were fighting you were experiencing it
that back then 2011 there's there's
something happening in the UK with a
group called get the L out where they
were their their lesbians saying that
trans activists are a racing lesbianism
it's a very interesting space to
navigate because you have two
marginalized groups accusing each other
of being the oppressors which makes this
whole critical theory stuff meaningless
so the the lesbians were arguing
that when they go to young girls and
tell them the things they're feeling
mean they're trans and they should take
hormones they're actually erasing
lesbians by making them into men and so
their argument was like if if someone is
biologically female and likes biological
females they should be allowed to be
biologically female and like who they
like but the activists now at these
schools are prescribing hormone
treatment which very much change their
Community or as they said erase it now
there's something called the LGB
Alliance where they basically said it's
not just about lesbians it's about gay
individuals bisexual individuals so
they're basically saying get rid of the
trans transgender from LGBT oh
interesting so the whole thing has
created this this you know chaotic fight
yeah and it's uh it is spilling into our
children's lives like we have to it's
Politically Incorrect for a lot of
people to talk about this but it is
again your child's life and future and
so this is very visceral right the
reaction I think kids
um take care of their parents and when
you when you bring in external
influences to start
um
sort of erasing the influence of their
parents you can teach kids all sorts of
crazy things and I'll tell you this I do
not believe that these teachers have the
child's best interests at heart in my
experience my evidence for this I went
to public school right I got to
experience what it was like to deal with
these teachers who just don't care about
you and now to have them teaching this
indoctrinating Insanity they look
when these people talk about the public
health instead of the permanent personal
health we were talking to someone
someone about this on the show when they
start talking about the collective and
the greater good they're basically
saying they are utilitarians they're
willing to sacrifice you and your rights
and your Pursuit of Happiness for their
end game because they think the world
should be a different way and they're
willing to sacrifice you to get it yeah
so I I love teachers right because it
was Mrs alkie in Morgantown West
Virginia they gave me just a little
journal with no fist on the front that
made me a writer and um and she was a
white teacher and she didn't oppress me
she wasn't the white supremacist trying
to bring me down but we have to be
honest like the Nea resolution you read
they are pushing this now like this is
ideology this is indoctrination then
there's another resolution that didn't
get as much attention but it was a
resolution by a school teacher in
Chicago suburb and there she wants to
teach the anti-israel pro-palestinian
argument and that's something that I
know a little bit about and this is
another one of the little books I
brought which is Angela Davis one of
their you know uh reading the people you
see the lady who uh she was the um the
sort of
1960s activist that black panther got in
trouble got into trouble put lightly
yeah wanted to keep it neutral yes
from Ferguson to Palestine oh wow all
right so this is the Nexus and that's
what I know about as a Muslim like I
know that there is a intersection and
they are using it to push agendas and to
push politics so Nea on one hand is
pushing Abram Kennedy in critical race
Theory and on the other they've got a
resolution it might not have passed but
still the fact that a teacher thinks
that she can introduce this resolution
that's going to be anti-israel and then
basically push the propaganda of uh
ideology that wants to you know destroy
Israel from The River To The Sea so
that's what's happening too let's talk a
little bit about why they're doing this
first I want to show you the story we
have it from NBC 5 Chicago this actually
from January Illinois congresswoman uh
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna repeat what
you said but she uh she said that there
was one thing that the Nazis did that
she think they understood properly I'll
make sure I paraphrase a paraphrase I
because I'm not going to she said I'm
not going to quit I'm not going to read
it you can see it on the screen
um this congresswoman was heavily
criticized for essentially our uh making
a statement that the Nazis were
effective in a certain way and that was
targeting children NBC says a newly
sworn in Congress congresswoman from
Southern Illinois quoted Adolf Hitler as
she spoke outside the US Capitol saying
the Nazi leader she believed got one
thing correct rep Mary Miller was
speaking at a rally in DC when a Twitter
user posted the video Tuesday showing a
portion of her speech what she was
trying to say was that one of the goals
of the Nazis was to Target children so
that they could erase the the world view
of the parents and through that in about
20 years they won right and they took
over let me actually show you this we
have this um
this article from mssu.edu
they say Hitler's First Act of business
after the election was the revamping of
the German education system to to
include extensive military training as
well as anti-semitic propaganda he then
could use this brainwashing of the
children against rebellious parents
quote when an opponent declares I will
not come over to your side he said in
November 19 1933 speech I will calmly
say your child belongs to us already
what are you you will pass on your
descendants however now stand in the new
camp in a short time they will know
nothing else but this new community
and there you go right that's exactly
what they're doing now now I wanna I
wanna let you know why I'm uh I'm
pessimistic
you know they tried to censor Hitler it
didn't work
what was it in Germany there were
efforts to and he was imprisoned you
know he was that he was censored
it didn't work he was able to
indoctrinate people and children and
gained power and be became the fuhrer so
interestingly we see all of these these
these states saying they're going to ban
critical race Theory teachings and I
don't know if it will work telling a
teacher they can't teach this does that
mean the teachers are also going to be
like well I can't quote anymore are they
going to be like no don't tell anyone
they're doubling down I mean that's what
the Nea resolution is about it's
basically saying we're going to fight
this and we're going to make sure that
we teach it and um you know as you were
reading that quote I was just thinking
back to again why I know that this is
something that everybody's got to care
about because
when I was fighting the issue of how
extremism came into my Muslim Community
all I had to do is go back to this word
that everybody's learned now right the
madrasa the religious school that's
where they grabbed the kid they bring
them in they indoctrinate them in our
modern day it was the Saudi government
that was creating those schools in
Pakistan throughout the Middle East and
that's who Crea that's what created our
Taliban our jihadis of today
and now this has been our fight in our
my in that Community against an ideology
and we have made progress like I want
you to actually have hope because we do
have rights in this country we're taking
them to court in Fairfax County Virginia
we've sued the school district for
racial discrimination because they are
targeting Asians and explicitly doing so
um we have parents who are there's I I
was it was awesome I love it I saw not
my idea as an exhibit in a lawsuit out
of Illinois nice you know this is this
is what we have to do because parents do
have rights we have right to privacy we
have you know your kid doesn't have to
explain everything about their gender
their race their sexuality we have a
right to information about the
curriculum
um so yeah we can do it this book is is
is amazingly terrifying and crazy
so this is the book not my idea you
mentioned a book about whiteness so so
this was being taught to Children you
said it is yep Pennsylvania so I I just
opened up to one of your one of your
notes and there's one page it says
connecting means opening and opening
sometimes feels our cars parked over
here love like breaking the next page
um Mom I don't feel good uh oh should I
pull over says the mom
in the next page let me turn the page I
need to know what's going on what are
you talking about that's the mother
saying that why didn't anyone teach me
real history I do see color I see yours
mine and everybody's You Can't Hide
what's right in front of me
this is a child yelling I know what that
poly I know what that police officer did
was wrong this is the child speaking of
the mother
go with your instincts on this one
racial Justice is possible okay geez you
don't have to yell this is a book
explaining to a child why to argue with
your parents right what's really
fascinating to me is how it's the
opposite of of Christianity yeah honor
their father and their mother this one
is the mom's like what are you talking
about I I don't understand no Mom you're
wrong I know what really happened yes
and it was just a constant theme I'm so
glad you picked up on that page because
that's the theme that the kid knows
better and the kid is now taught by the
teacher who's going to teach them better
than their ignorant parents now here's
where it all comes together because sure
I referenced this uh educational piece
about Adolf Hitler and what he did to
Children the Communists did the same
thing they wanted the children snitching
on their parents yes so the parents
would be sitting there reading the paper
saying ah Stalin man Turn the Page and
then run to school my dad said this and
then the dad's in the gulag right right
and so many of the parents that are in
my the school that my son just graduated
from they survived the cultural
revolution and so they said they watched
kids snitch on their parents oh yeah and
they see trauma they have traumatic
memories back to that experience so I
just searched it again it was 1966 to
1976 that the culture of Revolution
happened maoism then of course continued
and continued has continued its tyranny
but this is what we're getting it's this
book's really uh quite an amazing piece
of propaganda for children in an earlier
segment the little girl is reading and
it says in the United States of America
white people have committed outrageous
crimes against black people for 400
years all along every step of the way
people who love Justice and love each
other have been fighting back you know
they take a morsel of truth right this
history this country has its bad history
as to most countries I mean look at the
look at the history of any European
nations see the horrible things they did
especially but I would say any Nation
right India has had tyranny by its own
people AF countries in Africa have had
tears the word in America what was that
the word slave comes from slav now
here's what's fascinating what this book
is doing is it's outlining what children
should do after they've been
indoctrinated by the cult mem The Cult
of worshipers at these schools
after they start teaching the children
these things and and and and demonizing
the country demonizing their own parents
the book then goes on to explain how the
child should yell at their parents about
how they were lied to how they don't
feel good how they do see color yeah
they're going to indoctrinate your kids
and then use books like this so the kids
have a game have a they're indoctrinated
not only on what to believe but how to
react to their parents when their
parents challenge them yeah and what
they basically are doing like for
example in a St Louis suburb
the curriculum design person literally
wrote a memo to the other teacher saying
this is the stuff that you should hide
from the curriculum wow online yeah wow
yeah this is this book you got you
should go right I mean look at yeah
first page is when grown-ups tried to
hide scary things from kids oh no not
again what Mom what not again
she says who is that with their hands up
why is that policeman screaming at him
right as if to imply the parents
secretly know what's going on but don't
tell their children right and and it's
always a conspiracy of Silence that the
parents are perpetuating that the
teacher now will break and of course
there are teachers we're getting leaks
from teachers all over the country we
have teachers who are just so afraid of
speaking up one great one awful example
Portland Oregon suburb Beaverton we got
a leak from a teacher that they had an
equity seminar and at the equity seminar
one of their Equity Warriors who's A
teacher told the others that they had to
go along with all of this anti-racism or
evolve and evolve or dissolve lose their
jobs
they should well walk away stop doing it
yes that's it's such a tragedy you know
that they're people of conscience who
really do not believe in any of this and
right now their livelihood is on the
line
yeah we got a dark future heading
towards us no we do not because we are
fighting back that's what I want to tell
you I am literally standing here like
sitting here the embodiment of a mom who
just captures you know the uh stories
from morning till night we do it we are
thousands of parents you know those
school board meetings that you're seeing
it's happening because courage is
contagious yes well look courage is
contagious let's hope Bannon was correct
when the parents see this stuff they
will step up and yell out they are
yelling out but but I will say there are
a lot of people online they say they're
scared to use their real names they're
scared to use their actual photos
they're scared to speak up at work
because they'll lose their jobs people
respond to me saying Tim you don't have
kids you have no idea what it's like I'm
not going to risk my family over this
right I know and my response is
but you are when you're when your little
girl comes home calling you the bigot in
the monster when she turns 16 and she's
reading all of the stuff and she says
you're evil you're evil and Esty and
runs away and hates your guts when your
child grows up grows up in a world being
told that they're evil and an oppressor
why would you sacrifice the the the the
world that your children are going to be
inheriting but I get it I suppose people
are scared and would rather put food on
the table and have their kid grow up in
a gulag for resisting than to actually
stand up now and fight hard to to to
succeed I get it it must be scary I'm
not gonna pretend like I know what it's
like to have kids but I can certainly
tell you you've got a stack of books how
many books is this 15. I know and we
left books back yeah yeah there's a
whole bunch of them but the thing is I
wanted to tell you that the parents are
figuring out ways you know what's
happening is they are setting up
Instagram Pages like woke at school fill
in the blank and exposing what's
happening they're sending us secret tips
you know with and they do check the box
that they want to be anonymous but
they're getting the information out the
documentation I wouldn't I wouldn't know
about not my idea except that a mom
wrote to us about it you know and said
this is messed up so that's where like a
single whistleblower right then allows
us to share it with the world and that's
where every single parent I think has so
much uh possibility of power whether or
not you know they take the big risks
because there are some people who will
take more risks than others and can but
but I think everybody's got a role so so
do you want to tell people your site
where people can send this stuff yeah
please go to
defendinged.org and um and it's really
simple form folks can fill it out and we
have moms working around the clock
chasing down these tips awesome so let's
let's draw this conversation out of the
schools and into what manifests in the
real world we mentioned this earlier on
this uh Gwen Berry Olympic Athlete goes
viral because she's third place Hammer
thrower for the U.S Olympic trials to
join the team she gets approved and when
the anthem plays she looks all angry at
the camera and you know doesn't salute
or doesn't put her hand on her heart and
then she puts a shirt on her head saying
activist athlete just a few years prior
she was holding up the American flag
with a smile on her face we can see how
this starts to manifest in the real
world we have a couple of these stories
first Squad member blast July 4th
celebrations black people still aren't
free this generated some controversy uh
Corey Bush a Democrat dismissed
Independence Day Sunday as a holiday
meant for white people before claiming
the land is stolen land and black people
still aren't free we also have Maxine
Waters who is not a a new member of
Congressman for a long time drags the
Declaration of Independence on July 4th
Maxine Waters would she have maybe she
would have but I kind of feel like she
wouldn't have gone this far to criticize
Independence Day were it not for the the
change in culture and the feeling that
this is what you need to say to be
accepted to be approved of
zooby the rapper has a thread and in it
he's like here's some things I've
learned over the past you know year or
so one of them is that people would
rather be socially accepted than be
right people would would rather
sacrifice their principles if it means
they will be socially accepted things
like that yeah he's correct well it's
Tribal right and so it's that concept
that I had to struggle with within the
Muslim Community when you dare to
challenge the Orthodoxy you get thrown
out of the tribe and we ended up for
example in our community fighting for
women's rights my mom didn't get
invitations anymore to the potluck
dinners and she said I don't want to go
to their potluck dinners and so that's
the sacrifice that you have to make when
yeah this is very important it's
inspiring to me this is very much a
cultural revolution yeah and so this
next story I want to highlight just a
few of these National Geographic tweets
the July 4th fireworks are racist smoke
targets communities of color
then we have the story NPR
decry's Declaration of Independence as
document with flaws and deeply ingrained
hypocrisies what are they working for
the crown now they want us to return to
the British Empire one of the arguments
made by many on the left is that if we
never had Independence then the slavery
abolishment Act of parliament in 1833
would have affected the American
colonies and ended slavery some 30 years
sooner maybe or I argue that if the co
if the southern colonies or the southern
states were still colonies of Great
Britain they would have actually pushed
back and it would have caused the same
level of conflict and strife and
potentially even resulted in a war for
independence or at the very least it
could have put pressure on the crown to
wait because they were like well we have
these colonies that produce for us we
don't need to understand is that it may
actually have been the American
Revolution which helped the UK and
slavery in that if the crown was still
taxing Southern States and the states
relied on slaves to produce the crown
may have been like well you know we're
making a lot of money over here we can't
just do it right but who knows we don't
know for sure what I can say is when
they come out with these nonsensical
statements like fireworks are racist
right what what's happening is they
introduced Juneteenth
then they disparaged July 4th I think
Charlie Kirk mentioned it was with
Evanston Illinois yeah that got rid of
their July 4th celebration but had a
pride and Juneteenth celebration yeah
and so it's the it's this indoctrination
of ideas spilling now into popular
culture right like what is it that you
can wear what is it that you can't wear
how is it that you signal you know your
amazing political correctness and so
this is the politics spilling into
everyday life and um I walked by the uh
grocery store the cereal aisle and had
the you know new cereal that's got all
the multiple yeah right right yeah
that's so weird The Pride cereal yeah
the pride cereal I mean so it's
commercialization that's now chasing
this new ideology and um and we have to
just use our critical thinking yeah yeah
Kellogg's has a a lgbtq pride together
cereal right I'm not sure what it is is
it just Fruit Loops don't know isn't it
seem like it I know that's exactly what
it looks like oops that's kind of
insulting what the heck yeah I'm pretty
sure it's just Fruit Loops it looks like
but it's got all the characters together
and it's really fascinating when you see
all these corporations changing their
logos it's a really funny meme where
it's a bunch of uh evil corporations
from video games and movies uh with
rainbow logos like umbrella Corps yeah
they make the zombies right and the
umbrella's got a rainbow one right
aperture Laboratories which is the the
experimenting on humans and it's a
rainbow yeah we get the massive
multinational corporations are on our
side apparently yeah I mean this is the
term that they call woke Capital right
the whole idea of the
industry Corporate America that's what I
spent 15 years reporting at the Wall
Street Journal I loved covering
marketing because marketing was
basically propaganda
interesting yeah and propaganda is all
this I mean you make it fancy you make
it colorful you make it read you know
you you confuse people you end up and
you end up selling your idea we want to
be optimistic that these conversations
and the parents standing up will
succeed but I worry that it's it's the
average person doesn't care at all now
the point Bannon was making was that
these moms are the average person who
are standing up being like what is this
so perhaps I think the important thing
is not necessarily to be optimistic or
pessimistic maybe just to be vigilant
right right and and pay attention yes
and stay focused and don't back down
yeah there's
um my favorite idea our president Nikki
Neely said it on an interview a while
ago that the price of freedom is
Vigilant Eternal vigilance yeah yes and
I'll tell you it really hit home this um
this Fourth of July weekend I went to
visit my parents in Morgantown West
Virginia took my Uno cards because I was
going to play Uno with my dad well in
the PTSA at the school from where my son
just graduated Thomas Jefferson High
School for Science and Technology we had
for parents sees the majority of the
PTSA seats and those four parents are
against critical race Theory they're for
merit and guess what the president-elect
is the first black president-elect
chosen for the PTSA and he's against
critical race Theory because he wants
Merit he doesn't want this like bigotry
of low expectations who wants their kids
to be told they can never succeed yeah
so this weekend
the minority party so to speak the
people who want to push critical race
Theory and race-based admissions they
staged a coup
and they'd tried to basically unseat
these parents who are trying to
change the policy so that we can fight
critical race theory in the school I
guess what we won we won we defeated a
coup and I do vigilance I do want to add
a little bit of a good news into the mix
because we can talk all negative and get
all down and people are like oh man but
we got the story from Fox Walmart
shoppers break out into Star-Spangled
Banner Over Fourth of July weekend in
viral video yeah the video is actually
quite incredible it's just people
shopping right when all of a sudden
everyone's standing around the aisles
and they're singing the National Anthem
yeah and that's in our hearts you know
that is so in our hearts and we were as
parents this weekend I didn't get to
play my Uno Harry didn't get to grill on
time with his family he was trying but
we were doing this because we love this
country and you yawn she stood in
Tiananmen Square to fight the oppression
there and this weekend what did she do
she created beautiful graphics with
flags of America talking about defending
democracy you know that's that's the
fight that's the vigilance that's the
vigilance that we're talking about and
And if every parent does it in whatever
corner of school system that they're in
wherever you are in Corporate America
wherever you are in uh in your
neighborhood you know uh HOA that wants
to now rule what sign you can put and
you can't put the Blue Line you know
flag up and all of the stuff like you
have to be vigilant and protect rights I
watched a little historical video about
the Star-Spangled Banner and what the
song actually means and I think a lot of
people probably don't know this because
I certainly didn't that what does it
mean with the rockets red glare the
bombs bursting in air gave proof through
the night the flag was still there it
was that as the bombs were exploding the
flashes of light you could then see the
flag just very briefly and every time
they would shell this this town or this
the city or the fort they would they
would still see the flag standing it
couldn't be knocked down and it actually
actually as The Story Goes it could be
Legend but they say the shells were
actually killing people and the flag was
knocked down several times finally after
the battle was over when they went back
to the fort and saw the flag's Still
Standing it was being held up by the
corpses of the man who refused to back
down that every time the flag would go
down they would have lift it back up as
they were getting shelled and then die
on the flag wow that's what it meant
yeah it meant that there was an
oppressive Authority that did not not
respect the will of the people and the
people of this country said we we will
not abide by this we will fight for our
freedoms
and now you have people who are using
these morsels of truth manipulations
lies and constant negativity to try and
take those freedoms away arguing what
that uh uh it's bad that we had
Independence because the crown abolished
slavery first it's like okay be like the
UK I guess with no guaranteed rights
yeah you know they want to get rid of
all these mascots and these names of
people that they decided are on the
incorrect side of history but ultimately
we needed all of those folks to get to
where we're at today and maybe the
journey wasn't perfect of course it
wasn't perfect and there were injustices
against all people but you don't the
fundamental reason why I oppose critical
race theory is because
it rightly says that there was a
hierarchy of human value but it
incorrectly now wants to bring a new
hierarchy of human value to people and
that's just fundamentally immoral and
ethical and unacceptable and that's what
we have to fight there there is more
good news it's also kind of bad news but
we got some good instance of bad news I
got the story here from timcast.com San
Francisco crime leads to reduced Target
hours another biggest story in the world
but this is actually important because
of the massive wave of of shoplifting
yeah Target and Walgreens have announced
they're going to be closing around 6 p.m
can you imagine that before dark before
you get out of work yeah or you know so
so you got to work maybe at five you're
gonna make a Target in time to get your
groceries probably not but this is part
of the death spiral the quality of life
is dropping so rapidly in San Francisco
San Francisco so let me talk about what
this means in terms of good news and bad
news well basically
what you have in San Francisco is
Praxis what they love to tweet about
they love tweeting this these leftists
these these uh you know Communists these
marxists they will show a video of
antifa beating some old person and
they'll put like a picture of a guy the
meme of the guy rubbing his face saying
Praxis like they love watching Auntie
just brutally beat white people or
something like that well this is what it
really looks like San Francisco crumbles
40 percent of San Francisco San
Francisco residents plan to leave due to
quality of life according to a poll so
here's here's the good news the good
news is these things don't work and we
still have a system in place where
people can flee these things and their
failures and that will strip a lot of
the power away it was perhaps easy in
some of these places in Europe and in
Germany because they were smaller or
there were weren't very many places to
go I mean look Russia and Soviet Union
were very big but the United States is
very diverse in terms of ideology and
there's always a place to rush to
because it's not sweeping from the top
down necessarily it's from the bottom up
so as San Francisco implements these
failing policies people just leave yeah
now the bad news the cities are failing
which is awful right there's crime
there's homelessness
and then these people who vote in those
politicians move to Texas where I there
was there's there's a thread from this
uh this woman that it's actually really
great it's uh Michelle tandler says
conservative Twitter is all over this I
highly recommend reading the quote
tweets for a deeper understanding of how
many how many in America view SF the
left Etc this individual actually points
out as a Democrat that the cities are
very much in trouble
saying you know nobody is saying we are
X percent up in this category it's how
they feel walking the streets it's
walking Us stroller next to a tent
there's a pile of bikes next to it it's
being screamed at or chased by someone
who seems mentally unstable what I'm
seeing is that there is a big enough
incident it shakes people up if there is
it could be seeing a robber try to climb
through your child's bedroom being
pulled off your bike having someone
chase you with a pipe these incidents
Shake people up and they're friends too
ultimately I think the biggest
responsibility of government is to
protect people from one another it is
the place it is it is in place to
protect us from assault theft robbery
Etc right now the criminal justice
system in SF is not working it is
allowing people to get high on very
powerful drugs and terrorize one another
neighbors stores it is allowing rampant
theft burglary car break-ins it is
allowing mentally unstable felons to
stab elderly women
what do people say in response to these
threats where are you moving to I'm
moving to Texas
no don't they're gonna and they're gonna
vote more of the same and and change
taxes potentially right yeah but people
are moving with their feet right they're
they're making decisions with their feet
and I think at The Ballot Box like I'm
confident that this is going to impact
this issue is going to impact
gubernatorial race in Virginia any races
we have this year and then the midterm
election I should read some more of this
uh she says my whole life I've
considered myself a proud liberal
Progressive San Francisco Democrat today
I am ashamed of my city I see smug
ignorance of the laws and of unintended
consequences moral grandstanding winning
over data logic and facts radical
candidates winning elections unopposed
social justice Warriors getting into
government and wreaking havoc on
neighborhoods businesses and children
what why have we been asleep at the
wheel where is our sense of civic duty
civic pride is this who we want to be
perhaps
what these children are learning will
will be the shock to the system of of
the moms maybe seeing SF become a a poop
proliferator wasn't enough I don't live
in San Fran I don't care what they do
then one day their kid comes home with
this book and says mom why did you lie
to me you racist right right why did you
lie to me about who I am and what I am
and I can't trust you and it's not just
a typical parent-child debates or
disputes I mean this is like essential
to like deceit you know that's what
they're basically teaching is parents
have been deceitful I mentioned this
several times in the past week or so but
but it is extremely relevant to this
that I went to a skate park and there
was graffiti black lives matter which
was fascinating to me because the
graffiti I see growing up was very
anti-establishment of the system things
like that well what's so comical is all
you have to do being an investigative
reporter I love to look at this thing
called 990s which are the IRS filings of
501c3 organizations
you look up black lives matter movement
and they have millions of dollars in
their coffers they've got as we know
their Founders have multi-million dollar
you know homes and mansions that they're
spending on follow the money like that's
what I've had so much thrill doing being
a Nancy Drew in all these school
districts following the money because
when you actually look at how they're
spending their money and how they're
getting wealthy off of it they're just
corporations too yeah they are these
books I would imagine you said that
state funds are paying for these books
and so these authors are getting paid
out oh absolutely yeah
um Jason Reynolds just got eight
thousand dollars for 45 minutes in
Arlington Virginia on a zoom call wow 8
000
yeah but almost 200 a minute
that's the grift I love it I love when
these leftists are like uh so this is
really funny
um I got denied a home loan I've talked
about it before yeah I heard and uh so
finally I tweeted it was Navy Federal
right they sent me a letter in the mail
with false credit information which I'm
very angry by and of course as it goes
in today's modern era they they will
ignore you they will not you know so I
tweet about it knowing this is how you
get their attention right of course they
responded immediately and a bunch of
people mentioned how they wouldn't
respond to them because they don't have
millions of followers or whatever but
one person said Tim Poole is grifting
he's just trying to get people angry at
Navy Federal to make money or something
and I'm like what I'm who's got beef
with navy what are we talking about
right but but here's here's the one I'm
trying to make not to rehash the old
story
these leftists are using grift as a
preemptive Shield to accuse their
opponent that of which they do in an
effort to say oh he's only calling me a
grifter because I called him out for it
now he's trying to deflect right no the
reality is if I wanted to make money why
wouldn't I shill for amazon.com yeah and
walmart.com and the massive ngos why put
myself on in the out group in the
resistance fighting Against the Machine
the machine is safe the machine promises
you treasure in exchange for your
obedience yeah so
you know uh Twitter Jack uh Dorsey gave
Abram Kendy he didn't have enough money
already making twenty thousand dollars
an hour so he got 10 million dollars for
his anti-racism Center I mean that's a
lot of money right that could go into
building schools into developing
programs and sure enough it didn't
matter though he gets his 10 million one
month and the next next month he
collected twenty thousand dollars for an
hour this is Jason Reynolds guy he said
he got paid eight thousand yeah for Zoom
call was that uh State funds that he got
that was Arlington County Public School
money right across the border here
your tax dollars at work your property
taxes at work yeah and then uh the kids
got his book they got uh the 45 minutes
with him and and who paid for it though
you know who gave him the money
um Amazon gave them money wow so we got
a tip because all of a sudden these kids
were getting these books and this mom's
like where do they get these books so in
this case we discovered that Amazon's
public affairs guy called the diversity
Equity inclusion guy at Arlington Public
Schools suburb of DC and said we can get
you hot spots we can get you Wi-Fi and
the guy said no we want this book
we want 45 minutes on Zoom with this guy
so they they picked the candy instead of
Kindles just a minor correction it's
diversity inclusivity exactly die right
I love it I love it shows those words
yeah we gotta Rebrand it that's the game
they play don't find them their
territory yeah called the die cult I
love it it is the die cult and these
guys are killing America critical race
Praxis but then we'll just call it CRP
but we can just call it CRA yeah there
you go we'll just call it crap critical
race applied Praxis yeah perfect well
race is RA so the a can just be in there
oh yeah yeah I mean basically we got to
use their words against them and I I
it's so important that we focus on that
it's the Praxis and not the theory
that's being taught yeah they're not
teaching about the theory they're
indoctrinating and making people behave
with that theory as they study all sorts
of yeah stuff so this is the theory
right right here this is the Bible this
is their their yeah you love this this
is this is oh yeah I love to back up
Chris Ruffo because who was right on
Joanne reads Kimberly Crenshaw is in
there and then who are you going to read
from now this is I'm going to read uh
Crenshaw yep so she's the mother of
intersectionalism the one who decides
that Zionist feminists are not feminist
enough
so I wonder if there's a little bit more
context I could read but um I'll just
read one very simple portion it says
principally organized by Kimberly
Crenshaw Neil katanda and Stephanie
Phillips the workshop Drew together 35
law Scholars who responded to a call to
synthesize a theory that while grounded
in critical theory was responsive to the
realities of racial politics in America
indeed the organizers coined the term
critical race Theory to make it clear
that our work locates itself in the
intersection of critical theory and race
racism and the law what does that mean
critical theory is essentially a Marxist
philosophy a oppressor and oppressed and
what the the critical race theorists
were basically saying was they didn't
think Marx understood the realities of
racism in America that it was easy in
this small insular country and
um homogeneous country to say it's class
it's the wealthy and the poor it's the
worker and the bourgeoisie it's the
proletariat in the United States race
plays this role so they decided to take
that that framework and apply race to it
so it is very much rooted in Marxist
critical theory ideology Etc there's a
bunch of other components to this as
well the Frankfurt School it goes on but
when when Joanne reads says to
Christopher rufo it's not Marxist it's
not true
she's lying ibram candy said critical
race theory is a huge component of his
work and anti-racism and what it means
they're trying to hide from you what's
really going on yeah and so this book is
published 1995. okay long before any of
this trickles down into our K-12 schools
and she had had the workshop that Tim
just read about was in the 1980s at
Harvard Law School with Derek Bell oh in
fact yeah in fact I could be wrong I
believe the Ford I read was from Cornell
West oh okay all right great so uh faces
at the bottom of the well became it's
written by Derek Bell The Godfather of
critical race Theory at Harvard yeah you
want to check it
um so so
this you know this argument that they've
been putting forward that critical race
theory is not taught in schools one it's
being deployed it is Kimberly okay great
it's good to check the facts about
that's the interest yeah
um but so it has been a long journey you
know and it is a lot it has been a long
journey since the 1970s when it was
first formed in that Workshop that you
read they were the architects of it in
1980s the book gets published in the
1990s and now wow what do we have
notebooks and stamped workshops for kids
you know it's it's diabolical and it's
genius because it's so Insidious but but
ultimately it's it's
um evil I mean it really is evil let me
show you the perfect example of how
Insidious it is and and what do I mean
by Insidious slowly creeping yeah a
nefarious takeover yeah what do you
think when you when you know when the
left argues against this they say oh
critical race theory is not based on
Marx and they lie not being taught in
schools we've just proven throughout the
course of this podcast those are Lies We
have the book right here critical theory
is the base for critical race there it's
obvious they call it critical race
Theory right Frankfurt School Marxism
Etc they say that you know they're
fighting racism and here's one of my
favorite lies this right here is from
Chris Murphy Chris Murphy is a U.S
senator from Connecticut with a million
followers Chris Murphy is either
dangerously stupid a cult member himself
or a grifter he says stop the woke mob
with a photograph of civil rights and
they're saying um you know here's one
you know we demand uh we demand an end
to what's it say racial Prejudice or
something or police brutality UAW says n
segregated rules in public schools stop
the welcome mob I'm pretty sure if you
go to any intellectual dark web
Progressive or liberal or conservative
and ask them do you agree with that sign
and segregated rules in public schools
they will tell you yes of course we do
why would we want to stop this mob of
people we agree with and here's my
here's my response a clown Emoji
highlighting UAW says and segregated
segregated rules in public schools and a
photo I believe this was from Seattle it
could be wrong where they have a
diversity Equity inclusion inclusivity
session for people of color and next to
it for people who are white right they
are segregating this is what we are
complaining about share these things
with with your friends and family who
don't believe you who think but they're
just trying to teach the history of
racism and Republicans are trying to ban
it no we're trying to make sure that
when they teach history of racism they
don't encourage more of it like Ibraham
Kennedy does yeah and so we just filed a
thing that you're allowed to do in this
country that I don't even know about
called a civil rights complaint with the
office of civil rights it's with the
Department of Education and it was for
Wellesley Massachusetts Public Schools
so we all know about the tragedy in
Atlanta of the women and men also who
were shot and murdered right many of
them Asian so Wellesley Public Schools
this one school decides that they're
going to have a healing space so you
always love your healing space right and
you'd like to go you'd like to go
because this was a shocking story
White's not welcome I mean to be fair
you know you and I are both Asians so we
should we should just make sure
because you know what it was not my idea
oh there you go yeah so I I have in the
car you know another incarnation of this
that I didn't get to bring up
it's for it's for you and particular
where they now have uh hoodies
white Womanhood is white supremacy
because they gotta go away to you yeah
well actually we screwed it's all my
fault we do have this other story this
is funny parents at exclusive 57 000 a
year all girls private Manhattan school
right that counts Gwyneth Paltrow and
Katie and Kerry Washington among alumni
reject apology after video mocking white
women was shown to students
they're going to keep doing this stuff
yeah they are until people say no more
you know that this is unacceptable this
is values that we don't believe and they
can't the the thing that the thing that
we've learned is that you cannot be
shamed because the their tactic of
silencing people is to shame you and
people have to be Unapologetic in who
they are and what they believe and not
allow shame to silence them that's why I
like what you're doing it lets people
around the world really organize to show
like what's crazy in their you know
sector because if they come out one at a
time they get the vhmits they get the
Target and then they get shamed right
but if everyone's coming up together
yeah can't We're In It Together there's
no then you actually don't feel shame
when there's other people that are also
you know feeling your Vibe yeah yeah you
know one of the biggest problems I think
is is that you look at the groups that
are willing to stand up
it's just identitarians you know you've
got the alt-right who are going out and
marching and getting attacked or
whatever or like you know white
nationalists and whatever will come out
and they'll fight people and not so much
relative to the left the left will go
out with their you know surely in
protest many of them wear masks don't
don't want anyone filming but in their
workplace they'll wear masks that say
like black lives matter they will freeze
take them off they'll uh wear shirts
they'll get in trouble say we don't care
they stand up they yell they're secretly
going into schools they are actively
infiltrating government institutions
right and so what do you end up with
regular classically liberal-minded
Americans people believe in the founding
fathers aren't doing all that much
oh yeah we are we're fighting I am one
of those people you know I am always
voted Democrat I am a liberal I'm
classic liberal a feminist you know all
of these quote identities and
um I'm I'm fighting it in the same
reason why we fought in our Muslim
Community and keep fighting for reform
of those bad ideas because these are
ultimately bad ideas it's starting to
come up I think it's cause for Hope and
optimism especially you know with the
school season coming up we'll see how
things play because it really did
explode over the past year but what I
mean to say is you'll see antifa go out
and beat people yeah you'll see in some
circumstances you know there was one
recent thing I guess happened in
Philadelphia where some group came out I
don't know a whole lot about it but you
don't see moms marching against critical
race theory in the streets maybe yet so
maybe maybe that change needs to come
this year and then maybe we'll see it in
the next spring or fall yeah stay tuned
stay tuned it needs to happen yeah you
know more people need to go be at work
and say no to these these racist
programs yeah when you get you have to
you know choose and you know their new
buzzword affinity group is their new
buzzword right for segregation you have
to say no to it and you have to say that
I don't believe in segregation and you
know this is uh taking men out of
Lockheed right for their white supremacy
retraining camp like they have to say no
to this yeah did you see the Sacramento
Public School System document where they
said they were one they wanted white
children to form white Affinity groups
to understand their history and shared
culture oh yeah I'm like that does not
sound like
anti-racism right well I suppose it does
sound like anti-racism I guess
anti-racism is just code word for being
racist because they support the same
things yeah I mean it really is racism
like anti-racism is racism critical race
theory is racism like that's where we
have to be straight up about it anytime
people judge people by the color of
their skin it's racism it's like
flammable and inflammable
right right exactly and um and you know
the real hope that I have is that that
people are running for school board
races now that that you know Tech not
that uh strategy that they had to bring
people into local office parents are
picking that up they're doing it don't
you love it that the school systems the
Educators they're getting angry at
parents because we're filing Freedom of
Information Act requests they're like oh
no how dare you actually use your your
citiz your right as a citizen to demand
contracts and curriculum and so they're
going after parents for that but the
parents are doing it they're filing
these these uh requests I think it's
time we start calling them critical race
application practice sessions
I don't know maybe that's bad because
craps is a fun game yeah yeah yeah crap
only not crap critical voice Praxis I
like the Praxis word yeah because this
critical Grace theory is not racist
studying critical race Theory isn't
racist you're studying the tenets of
critical race Theory you're learning it
you're learning but integrating the
Praxis into your behavior is inherently
call it critical race in practice
yeah that's a nice one I like that yeah
then see when all the gang members are
like nah you see that video from the
there was a video from the salon where
this like Mexican dude or I guess was
fighting and people were saying that he
was like a gang member or something like
that I'm like I don't know if that's
true whatever there might be people
being racist because the guy was like
Mexican they were like he's a gang
member because he's bald or something
like that right but I I do know that um
in Chicago
a lot of the Latin Kings very religious
and I have to imagine a lot of the older
you know members are not going to like
what they're done what they're doing to
these kids oh yeah I I mean there is so
much uh
uh you know uh Kool-Aid that they're
forcing kids to drink and they I mean
what parent wants that because
especially if you have a pride in your
identity you don't actually want people
to start saying that you are the
oppressed right like you are trying to
actually teach your child that you are
empowered and you can do whatever you
want to do and so there's a mom named
Norma she came from Peru and she is just
so angry that they are making such
assumptions about hispanic kids you know
yeah she's like this is insulting and
and I don't I don't uh she says I don't
um hate Asian kids that might be going
into this school I actually learn from
them like what is it that their parents
are teaching them that about good values
there's this viral tweet I guess where
someone said that English is the
colonizer's language and to speak
Spanish or whatever people are like uh
Spain like what do you like The
Conquistadors dude right they're brutal
yeah and you know there's such myopia in
this telling of quote truth a few weeks
ago I went to one of the protests by the
social justice educators of DC yeah and
there they were chanting like a cult I
pledge to teach the truth and it's their
truth that's the problem some people are
saying critical race at practice
nice I like that crap sessions yeah
right right crap they're teaching crap
to our children yeah don't call it crap
it's critical no no it's critical race
of practice I love the I love the
creativity because basically we've got
to how do you how do you dismantle
propaganda right yeah yeah
well so when I was onto a propaganda
right when I was at the skate park I
mean I see these little kids and they're
sitting you know they got all this
graffiti propaganda of black lives
matter and other woke nonsense and then
me and my friends started laughing about
like what loser is gonna come out here
and be like Walmart what up up like I'm
repping walmart.com and the kids there
hear us mocking the ideas that's what
you need you need to go there and
basically be like I'll tell you what
happens you go to a skate park and you
see a bunch of kids and the the alpha
kid you know the kid who's good is going
like yo black lives matter yo but then
when a pro shows up someone who's older
and really good and they do a Trey flip
crook down the 10 rail that all the kids
are like oh and then he starts making
fun of the kids for their stupid
propaganda those kids will change their
tune in two seconds yeah but then that
that pro has to have the courage right
and they want to do that and they don't
the challenge is then they're afraid of
losing their sponsorships their
endorsements and all the rest all it
takes is for some
um charismatic individuals to be there
to to be to inspiring young people and
telling them to get away from that
propaganda you don't even got to be
doing Trey flip I listen to your
interview with Candace Owens and she
said and you said also that you get so
many phone calls right and so many
conversations with so the quote a list
that afraid to come out of the closet
criticism but but they believe it they
counter this belief I wasn't I was
invited to a couple like a-lists or
Hollywood parties and I was like why
would you why would why like why would I
go to this they're like oh man it's like
it's low-key you know you ain't got
anything to worry about and I'm like I
don't have anything to worry about it's
you guys you're scared to speak up
you're right there's like it was it was
like TV show a list it wasn't like you
know Robert Downey Jr or anything like
that it's like a bunch of people who are
in prominent shows we're gonna be at
this Hollywood party and I was just like
I I the idea that
you know with all due respect I'm gonna
come out and have a good time and laugh
and and and and you know break bread and
have a beer with you guys when you're
sitting here saying we completely agree
but we will never defend you publicly
I'm like I'm not cool with that yeah
yeah and it is tough and I uh you know
now I don't know about you all but like
I am just uh surround myself with folks
who are challenging this kind of
ideology because I don't want to be
dragged down by people who are just
hemming and Hauling and cowardly really
in society like I get it because I went
I've reported in Pakistan and in
Afghanistan you know and Saudi Arabia
where ex extreme identity politics kills
right and and I I really fear for
America like we are headed in that
direction and I don't want that like
when you were talking about the Target
closing at six o'clock I thought to
myself man that's what happens like in
war zones right that's what happens
that's what would happen in a country
like Pakistan on because it's dangerous
after dark and that's where sectarianism
kills and and all the immigrants from
Lebanon Iraq you know Egypt like they
understand the dangers of this China yes
Eastern Europe right yeah let's rate
some super chats and see what the
audience has to say if you haven't
already
give that like button a little tap show
your support subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends and get
your super chats in we're going to start
reading as much as we can and uh we'll
we'll read your opinions on critical
race at practice or Crap as it's called
yeah that's right nay Slayer says I'm
dubbing July 5th through November 10th
Gadsden flag appreciation season fly it
to show your red pill status between
Independence Day and Veterans Day I put
my flag out this morning someone sent me
the end cap Gadsden flag oh it's really
cool but I'm gonna end cap but I still
like the flag so I'm like I'm gonna put
it up like half black it's black and
yellow it's so it's yellow and you know
it's like it's split in the middle and
I'm like you know it's a good flag I
like the dancing flag nice yeah
rodzilla this is an earlier super said
uh they are not teaching CRT they are
applying it applying its principles
uh oh critical race applied principles
great there we go there's crap all
around that's right yeah they they are
implementing critical race applied
principles they're implementing crap
that's right
they are flushing crap down your
children's throats this is how great
ideas are born
critical race applied principles there
you go beautiful
Cecil Rhodes says the left leftists are
so extreme that normies are starting to
notice in Mass looking for an answer and
the right stands waiting with that
solution yes perhaps
all right I'll fight you naked says the
woke are creating a backlash of white
racism to counter their anti-white
racism when they have sufficient numbers
the woke will turn to the rest of us and
unironically say we told you they are
racists we will say no you made these
people
as a mean that goes around where it's a
bunch of people who are white being
yelled and demonized and then all of
those people then stand next to each
other and then they yell at them why are
you forming a racist group wow yeah oh
yeah and it is creating division that is
what I know and I can see and fear
amongst people that would never have
even questioned each other's
relationship business yeah yeah the
Civic nationalist says I would like to
say a good Fourth of July despite being
belated even though I am notoriously Pro
Monarch I think the US is the embodiment
of Luck's ideas and how it can work God
Save the Queen and God bless the USA
much respect the Civic nationalist
perhaps what needs to happen is the good
luck inspired Americans should storm the
beaches of
what's a what's a good beach in the UK I
don't know I don't know London Dover
I've been to Nuki and liberate you from
not the crown but from the lack of a
written Constitution and the oppression
of these these I guess I don't know a
crappy Parliament yeah
I know we got some of our own issues so
yeah I want us to fix America's
miles kinslow says Hey guys there's a
woman named Gabrielle Clark fighting CRT
with a landmark case please hear her
story we'll appreciate it so much
absolutely she's a mom in Nevada and her
son is multi-racial that's right yeah I
remember the story and he had to choose
there in the classroom you know and was
white passing and so he had to carry the
sins of whiteness upon his back and
thank goodness she fought back she filed
a lawsuit and she's Fierce yeah right on
internet's acting up a little bit but
we'll read anyway arceon says Tim is an
interracial interracial man did you ever
experience racism from your Asian side
of the family against your white side
many Asians are racial purists not in my
family uh although I hear that down the
family line racism was uh
prevalent in the in the Asian side of my
family but uh I think it's everywhere
there's only so far back I can oh I can
go on the Korean side of my family
though because of the war and because of
you know the splitting of Korea and
everything like that so not a whole lot
I can I can say that you go back two
generations pretty much everybody was
racist yeah I mean what I find a really
offensive intellectually about the
argument that white people have a
monopoly on racism is that we know in
every other part of the world that
racism exists brown people against black
people black people against brown people
black people against white people I mean
it just goes on and on in circles it's
just power it's power we got a bold one
Raptor's Talent he's heated he says I
warned my parents about CRT
um well to be to just to clarify real
quick it's it's critical race uh applied
principles correct yeah I told my family
that this was coming and what did they
say oh that will never happen in
Oklahoma oh that won't happen in our
school well how about now I told
everyone how the stupidity was
infiltrating the school system all the
while these SOB said I was overreacting
have fun this is all caps by the way
yeah it was all caps I know how you feel
man
um I've repeatedly warned about certain
things that have happened and uh people
don't don't pay attention you just you
gotta say look you said this crap wasn't
gonna happen but this crap is happening
I mean you just got to tell them yeah
and you just you just say I was ahead of
my time and you've got to pay attention
to me you know what you do it's really
really simple
crazy no no no no listen when you when
you approach these people who are
indoctrinated as their enemy they lock
down you approach them as a friend it's
all about the tone the the the the three
principles are poor extreme in turn in
this instance I'll give you something
very simple you say we're here to teach
people about the history of racism these
Republicans they're so awful we're going
to be teaching people about critical
race applied principles and so we would
like your kids to come to the session
right and then literally what we are
teaching c-r-a-p and they're like wait
it says you're teaching our kids crap
you go
oh well well I mean uh that's that's you
don't call it that right correct therapy
and then when they're like what but you
got the idea this is going to happen on
your road show
teaching this is what I Envision you're
gonna expose crap everywhere they're
teaching crap in schools it's about time
critical race applied principles yes
it's funny because that is a better way
to describe it critical race theory is
like a legalist's analyzing of the law
right but what they're doing is they're
applying its principles so the schools
are implementing crap critical race
applied principles yeah that's good that
you chose that too because the Practical
definite the literal actual definition
of Praxis is the application of a theory
right it's an applied principle yeah
perfect exactly perfect it is you got it
yeah
right
all right Gabriel McLeod says CRT seems
to imply that Society has made no
progress if that were true we would not
be able to identify how absurd it is
when juxtaposed against objective
reality the point of
CRT is not to have a discussion as
discussion leads to resolution uh just
for moving forward I'm going to replace
all instances of CRT with crap yes
because I want to make sure we're being
accurate and I I know it's funny that
we're making fun of it but in reality
I've said
When you mention they're teaching
critical race theory in schools they say
what book have they ever brought up by
Dave Bell or Kimberly Crenshaw you're
lying it's because they're teaching crap
critical race applied principles yeah
they're just hiding the the you know
ball so to speak and we have to call it
out that's right
BlackRock beacon says just moved from PA
to Florida I had to have the talk with
my young daughter about how public
school is a tool to indoctrinate her in
radical ideology destroy her
individuality and turn her into an
obedient worker in the tax Minds for the
Elite Class
wow yes and what I say is you know get
some of these bad books also and read
them yourself so that share it with your
kids so that they can be educated about
how they are going to be miseducated yes
right so they have a self-awareness yes
cult uh whereth where wraith says these
critical race theorists I wish I could
make them see the path but tempting as
that sounds I'll have to pass oh well I
do think you need the full context of
that quote for it to apply here properly
because this way it just kind of sounds
like you're saying you're not going to
even bother trying to talk to people
right but for those who are not familiar
it's actually a lyric for my song where
it's I wish I could save them and make
them see the past make them see the path
but tempting as it sounds I'll have to
pass I know what's needed for the good
of my people to save them so the line is
basically saying instead of teaching
people what you know the the the the
line from that song is the critical race
theorist it's the indoctrinator saying
instead of explaining it I'm going to
lie cheat and steal because I know
what's best for everyone else but uh I
appreciate the call ends justify the
means in the mind of the site if you
haven't already seen it you should check
out will of the People by Tim Poole on
uh you can search for it on YouTube
you'll find it it's a song almost a
million views are gonna break a million
views soon that's fantastic that's also
on Amazon and iTunes I have one song
that's published but I have like 50
billion songs we've never published oh
coming soon that's great yeah yes really
good one culture
Gregory Nicholas says critical theory is
infecting FL as we speak through uh
South FL Chamber of Commerce Tim how
should one report or document what they
see
through the Chamber of Commerce he said
so where is South FL what is he talking
about South Florida oh it's just south
Florida chamber of commerce so you know
what I say is that folks have to expose
and educate the community if it if he
sees it and he doesn't want to go on
record about it he needs to call the
local reporter and show them this story
tell him I'm a whistleblower I want to
be not for attribution do you know what
I'm saying like you gotta use the means
that are out there
if he has the ability he can write his
own column for the local paper and
expose it you know that's what I'm
saying like what you guys are doing too
with your journalism Vision right is
Empower people to be able to spread the
truth as we see it right before our eyes
you you I'm looking forward to that
dispatch out of South Florida yes Logan
Culver says Tim I can no longer type in
chat I get a notification that says I
can't because I subscribe to this
channel while watching a video made for
kids weird have you tried unsubbing and
then resubbing maybe he says I get an
error when hitting the notification Bell
WTF is going on uh I call it pressure
it's it's not Banning someone but you
put your thumb on the scale to make it
harder and then over time the channel
dwindles and dies not because you banned
it but because you're strangling it
slowly it seems to have something to do
with uh the setting where now you have
to be subscribed to the channel to chat
to type in the real time chat it was the
day we turned that on is when people
started getting that message yeah but
that's clearly not an issue that's
supposed to be happening so
YouTube's gonna say it's an error
obviously it's affecting some channels
and not others very weird yeah
yep yep
all right Sonny James says will someone
tell me the difference between Marx and
Hitler besides Minor Details both
believed in centralized control the
banks One Believes in the area and the
other in the Ubermensch the language for
totalitarianism is here essential and
none I mean they have the similarities
and their differences that's why I say
it's really dumb when people Compares
everyone to someone else when they're
like you're a fascist or you're a Kami
it's like bro they're the the whether or
not they determine the state should
provide you Health Care is less relevant
to the fact they're going to throw you
in a camp more execute your family Marx
was very wealthy he was born super
wealthy I know that Hitler was born I
think of modest means and served in
World War One basically had his
psychology his mind blown out running
from trench to trench which he had like
what they call that um shell shock you
know he was like nuts after World War
one so that that they were very
different in that respect yeah but I
think I I also don't get lost in you
know some people want to play uh like
who was the first philosopher where the
roots of all of this especially for moms
and dads I think the bottom line is this
is crap and we are not going to accept
it today like that's how I complicated
it I did tweet about this I said uh
critical theory is extremely complicated
they made it that way on purpose they do
not want you to understand what they
think the only thing you need to say is
uh heck no right you just need to say no
you need to learn to recognize it and
just say no right exactly you don't get
into their game don't yeah don't play on
their Turf critical race applied
principles that's right V radio says we
need to get this guest on Joe Rogan
yeah great well
that's your thing
does uh Ian could you go on the roof and
turn on the Rogan signal right exactly I
know I didn't know you guys had the bat
cave here yeah
mskgwd says great show Tim I'm
especially excited to see tomorrow's
podcast men have chosen their paths
after Awakening to the Dynamics of this
modern society oh interesting
doobie McNasty says Dr Kellogg was a
twisted dude I'm not surprised the
company took that step his whole mission
was to change that the people uh change
the people live and think yeah the the
invention of corn flakes you know why he
invented Corn Flakes I do no I don't he
didn't want little boys to be you know
exploring just you know kind of sinning
in private if you know what I mean what
going blind so he thought that corn
flakes would stop that I guess
they now teach it you know in elementary
school yeah they do they actually teach
I mean on Full Circle yeah yeah we're so
Advanced now aren't we yeah that's great
BlackRock beacon says Navy Fed sold me a
house closed the contract I moved in
then after 30 days they nulled the
contract and kicked my active military
family out the week before Christmas no
lawyer would take the case even though
they all agreed it was very illegal I
mentioned this when when I got denied
for the loan because they sent me false
credit information that's why I'm like
this is serious I think it's illegal wow
you can't do that but um I mentioned I
was wondering if they were insolvent
like if the reason they're lying to get
out of a small loan is because maybe
after this past year you know a lot of
people like the banks are flush with
cash dim it's not true I'm like well
maybe not this non-profit you know this
Credit Union some other people tweeted
something similar that based on their
experiences getting rejected or denied
they also thought maybe they're you know
they've got more liabilities and Assets
in there in serious trouble and I'll
tell you this
um I reached out to them and I said I
want this corrected and they ignored me
I I I'll put it this way I hate the idea
that in modern society you have to have
a massive following to be able to get
any attention from massive corporate
right so the least I can say is there's
a lot of people complaining about
similar things and hopefully this does
something about it did you ask them if
they were racist
no I I I I I I you can always throw that
card out there right interesting as soon
as the Korean exactly
yeah that they probably would have
listened to yeah instead I was like uh
uh I'm an honor broke right you guys
insolvent you can't afford this is not
in a big one yeah
Michael Malone says lucky show Tim would
you uh would you consider having Jack of
the survival podcast on your show
imagine Michael Mouse being a survival
expert and a duck farmer in Texas that
would cover a couple of layers of Jack's
personality sounds hilarious perhaps
we'll take a look into it
Zach Wilkerson
says your analogy to the rise of the
Nazis in the 1930s is not correct I was
just watching a documentary about
Hitler's rise to power and was getting
spooked by the similarity of our
situations oh is not incorrect that yeah
yeah right so I I saw um some tweets
where people were like you know they
tried to censor Hitler and and ban him
and it didn't work in the long run and I
see what's going on with Banning
critical race Theory and I'm wondering
if it'll work in the long run because
even if oh you know what let me rephrase
this I'll start from the beginning
conservatives are not cool
institutions are not cool politicians
are not cool
celebrities are cool
so the schools can say we're Banning
this stuff and you know what's going to
happen right the people teaching this
and so see we were right we told you
this would happen they don't want to
admit their privilege and their power
and then the kids who are spray painting
and markering up black lives matter are
going to see these celebrities being
like dude the machine is fighting back
keep fighting we're the resistance yeah
amazon.com yeah that's what's happening
that is exactly what's happening because
they are uh you know turning the parent
movement into a quote right-wing
conspiracy they're dismissing sincere
folks who are disturbed by these bad
ideas and then meanwhile they now become
the uh Victim Because of these laws and
so I like this is what all bad ideas
have to be defeated by better ideas and
so ultimately I we don't think that
banning will solve this problem but we
have to get enough people to decide that
these are really bad
all right Mr mocha lover says I'm a
small YouTuber that was live streaming a
game called Hearts of Iron 4 yesterday
and the mod I was using had you leading
your own small nation in a broken up USA
your portrait in game gives you quite a
thick beard can you grow one of course I
can't grow a beard I'm part Korean uh
that's apparently why I guess I'm
growing neck weird
uh it's the uh Archer Archer magiris
saying he says God blessed Tim and crew
of a Maria as a liberal entering the
traditional self-sustaining lifestyle
what is your opinion of us traditional
Catholics and other religious folk
living this way for decades hmm like uh
um oh like having chickens and stuff
smarter it's better families all the all
the the liberal climate change people
who don't do this I think are hypocrites
because it's fun it's easy it's cheap
you save money it's healthier it's
better for the environment everything
that they preach can be solved by
getting out of the Cities still being
close enough to commute with an electric
bike or even a bicycle or taking public
transport but for some reason they claim
we've got to do all these things but
they still want to live in these crowded
polluting cities right I know I grew up
in Rural America basically and I just
don't understand why we have to crowd
our cities anymore you know I walk down
High Street in Morgantown West Virginia
yesterday and just thought Wow Let's
invest in these sidewalks and these
these uh shuttered shops right this is
America
Brian B says within days of George Floyd
both the NJ and Nea teachers union sent
out emails about USA being white
supremacist and sent out CRT teaching
materials right about a month ago they
sent an email for summer workshops by
ibram Candy and Nicole Hannah Jones
exactly they were ready the author of
The 1619 project if listeners don't know
yeah yeah uh
Kim jongpong says my kids are almost
school age we're pretty well off and can
move anywhere currently in a liberal
city is homeschooling the only way
advice we've seen elements of CRT in
every in every decent private and public
school we've toured yeah homeschool pods
maybe yeah I mean it's that's the choice
that parents are making now and uh these
school systems are going to suffer
because ultimately the best and the
brightest are going to be you know
choosing differently they're going to be
having even greater Equity gaps because
kids and families that can't have
choices and they don't care though
because this is all in pursuit of their
their very fake anti-racism agenda Sonny
James says before America institute's
critical race applied principles most
Americans mainly the far left are most
are most ignorant to race there's three
distinct groups that splinter off I'd be
banned for naming but FYI most
Caucasians aren't Lily White
I always find it really weird that um
Caucasian is like when you're listing
race like from the Caucasus region right
right Russia or something I'm not from
the caucuses yeah I know it's really
weird like it's anglo-saxon's not an
option yeah and being from India you
know where the supposedly the original
Aryans right like this is the confusion
about so many of these words and these
identities and these names and
um but but what's the great greatest
tragedy now is that this is what people
are seeing right instead of the human
being right yeah Danny Douglas says Tim
can you please put will of the people up
on Spotify love it it is on Spotify you
need only search for Will of the People
by timcast on Spotify and you can listen
to it right now it's on iTunes as well I
think it's on every I think it's on
Pandora too I don't know whatever
it's weird I Heart Radio yeah I'm pretty
sure it's it's on you know all of those
yeah definitely
critical race applied practice uh big
papazo critical race applied practice
crap that's right yep crap catching on
uh genola says is Marxism but with
without its only good thing anti-corp
that's what's funny right because I
actually think there is an issue between
classes right there's the ultra wealthy
exploding the poor and I think critical
race theory is their tool to deflect
from it yeah it's such a tragedy I mean
you can see it anywhere and everywhere
right and that is what I knew growing up
in West Virginia is that the white
families were really part some of the
most disenfranchised in this country and
that's why as a person of quote color I
reject the idea that it's only the
whites that are oppressing others yeah
this is great
okay
Kendrick Leist says educators are
teaching critical race applied practices
for diversity inclusivity and equity
eat crap and die
[Laughter]
I love it that's great
make 1984 fiction again says hope Jimmy
dore's watching this because he denies
CRT being taught too aegon face Jimmy
you're great uh check out the show on
critical race Theory and and pay
attention of these books that are being
taught to kids Jimmy's Awesome by the
way he's cool dude
um
Robert Adams says you need to believe
that every person is responsible for
their own actions every other form of
government is just putting lipstick on
the same Pig
Poor Pig
Aaron says four people died in the
Battle for Fort McHenry I heard the same
recording recounting the bodies holding
up the flag in the fire academy it's
bunk that's why I said is probably
Legend yeah
it's apocryphal but the mythology is
still inspiring right because ultimately
that's the kind of symbolic sacrifice
that many people have to make well that
evokes the image on Iwo Jima where the
soldiers are holding up that flag it's
very like resonant with the American
people but to clarify you're saying it
was a lie and it is war propaganda
uh that's what this individual is saying
okay but you know we we have just
kidding I love you you know it could be
a Pocketful for propaganda maybe two all
right
Josh Bronco says hi Tim and gang I
believe you keep mispronouncing cult and
culty the L is actually pronounced as an
N yes I'm from Australia also can we can
we get a crossfire with lids and a
radical feminist that'd be cool that'd
be fun yeah I don't know if I'm for it
Abe Eckstein says hashtag band crap
should be trending on Twitter yeah yes
BlackRock beacon says I'm in NFL but
willing to work with folks in South
Florida to get that story out find me on
mines m-i-n-d-s I'll work with you to
push it out I might be a small Channel
but I'm independent and stubborn very
cool BlackRock uh Beacon and feel free
to write to me I I have open DM on
Twitter so I lost for no money you guys
people could reach out from all over and
I'm happy to edit and op-ed anywhere
awesome yeah right yep DK says online is
not the same as IRL I do speak out in
real life online is far scarier because
the mob is terrifying yeah yeah
true
CB says Praxis means activism they can
change the words of critical theory and
still requiring Allied Praxis from the
students that's right slippery blip
squeak says Tim quote wanted little boys
to stop you know guest quote now they
teach it in schools Ian quote we've come
full circle right indeed I mean it's
it's creepy stuff you know what what's
what's going on with a lot of this uh
it is
it like what they're doing with kids is
I didn't know all these books were in
the school this is like a [ __ ] this is
like a shock to my system like I'm the
frog in the pot and I just got a spark
yeah I'm glad I'm really glad that it
was effective because
in our brains right there has to be
something that shocks Us in order to
know that it's a reality and so if this
worked then that's great because
it it was just an email from the
principal that woke me up you know this
like that's just these aha moments that
folks are getting when they're like oh
wait they're coming after me you know
and then it becomes real and personal
and then you see how wide it is how big
it is
I want to I want to read this one from
Kevin Kelly says went to Jersey City to
see one of my friends for the first time
in a while to find he went from a
Centrist to far left apologist got in an
argument over guns any advice on
deprogramming propaganda
that stuff yeah it's it's difficult um
there are psychological tricks but the
challenge is are you willing to use
manipulation and that's that's that's
that's the challenge because I certainly
know how to deprogram propaganda but
it's it's a it's a method to
manipulating someone's world view I'm
not a fan of that
so ultimately I just say here's the
truth except that I don't share this
video with someone and if they don't
believe it I don't tell you because if
you believe the ends justify the means
you're doing exactly what they're doing
you will never meet the ends because if
you live in a world where you're allowed
to use nefarious tactics to get what you
want
the ferris tactics will never stop being
used because everyone will just be like
well you did it I'll do it too when will
you ever actually come about that
utopian ideal unfortunately I don't
think you will
all right let's see we got a couple more
here
Jason Kyoto says the original blueprint
or archetype regardless if you believe
it to be mythology or not was the
critique of God's kingdom by Lucifer to
draw away a third of the Angels
critiquing and attacking a power
structure while instilling your own
that's creepy interesting yeah
manipulation yeah since the beginning of
time
all right let's just see uh we'll do uh
one more
Jasper Rollins says CRT is predicated on
atheism I'm sorry critical race applied
practices or crap
the letters in atheists can be array
range to spell eat ish
interesting all right my friends uh
thank you all so much for for hanging
out for the show if you haven't already
give that like button a smash subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends you know someone asked how do
you deprogram propaganda
share videos and clips and stories share
content invite people to events where
they're going to hear other ideas
surround them with people who know their
stuff you are the summation of the five
people who surround you
if people are being surrounded by
mainstream media lies then you need to
be there for them to be like ah nah
that's ridiculous and then look you're
sitting with your friend and they go
whoa Donald Trump just you know punched
a guy in the face then you go what are
you talking about I just looked it up
here and it's not it didn't happen and
they'll go oh
and you'd be like bro whatever come on
we're watching watching basketball or
something yeah don't let yourself get
angry that's for sure yeah how about
this Let Yourself Go to timcast.com
become a member because we're hiring
we're expanding it's getting crazy we're
filling up this building really really
quickly
um we had a lot of work happening and I
I I'm hoping the new site will be up
shortly uh we've gone over the Alpha
version of it already and it looks
amazing the news section I think we're
building something really revolutionary
it's almost like a social media site in
a sense where you've it's it's it's like
if an independent I don't know how to
describe it people are gonna have to see
it it lists the different shows we have
on one side there's a new section it's
really an interesting thing imagine if
like you went to Netflix and it wasn't
just shows you could watch but also like
a new section breaking information
commentary op-eds something like that
and it's all thanks to all of you who
are members so we're gonna have a bonus
segment coming up which will be up
around 11 p.m or so so make sure you
check that out you can follow us on the
show at timcastirl Facebook and
Instagram and you can follow me at
timcast on basically everything
did you want to mention your website and
your social media as well yeah sure
defendinged.org and you they can follow
me at astronomani asra
n-o-m-a-n-i email me at Astra
astronomani.com and um remember it's not
your idea this is not your idea so crap
is not to be taught by you or it's not
to be taken by you you have to fight
back yeah you guys can also follow me at
Ian crossland.net and on all social
media Ian Crossland thank you so much
for coming on oh absolutely
I am so gratified to me azra we had a
phone conversation before she came on
and I was like she's the perfect person
for the time you know how sometimes
these strong people rise to the occasion
she's one of those people and I'm
excited to see it happening and I for
one am extremely encouraged by what's
going on with parents uh speaking out
and up and you guys can follow me at
sour patchlitz on Twitter and I'm trying
to get more followers and Sour Patch
Kids so please help me we will see you
all at timcast.com in just a few minutes
or so thanks for hanging out we'll see
you there bye guys